well it's all about the heat in terms of
ted's department it certainly is yes and
a busy week
and of course
these are records that we're now proud
of we actually set a new record high for
the day today we knew it was going to
happen do you disapprove of my 12 noon
tea time tomorrow
your noon tea time tomorrow yes i
disapprove of it
no no no i always do so i have a i i
drink a lot of water out there no he i
do this all right 170. oh yeah right
from nasa i get the sunblock i do this
every summer yeah you do many times i
got to show you some numbers okay this
is uh interesting because these are the
number because i don't want to think
about your noon tea time you got to do
in the morning no i like babies
something's going on with me i enjoy it
right here temperatures
okay brian look at this okay so yours is
at noon
5 30 a.m 83 degrees that was today 10 30
a.m it was already at 100 degrees at 10
30 a.m noon time 106 degrees there's a
reason the excessive heat warning is in
effect because your overnight lows again
are warm so there's not much recovery
overnight the new record was set right
around 4 pm hour
109 degrees our official high for the
day today and that vested our previous
record of 108 set back in 1996. 106 in
centennials right now 110 north las
vegas these neighborhoods are hot 109
for sunrise manor one of five mountains
edge 107 for anthem right now 105 for
prep 118 for death valley right now hot
for you 113 laughlin 110 for mesquite
it's hot everywhere we pinpointed out
some of that moisture moving in from the
south yesterday in arizona it's moved a
little further north like we talked
about yesterday not quite here but
lightning strikes detected near grand
canyon near flagstaff but this can scoot
a little bit more westward tomorrow so
watch mohave county whether you get some
pop-up thunderstorms for some mid-level
moisture coming in from baja california
here's your weekend forecast okay so
saturday shooting for 190 degrees
tomorrow that could tie the record
tomorrow 109 setback 1956. sunday 106 no
record will be set that record on sunday
is 112. 96 on monday looks better right
96 monday cooler on monday even cooler
believe it or not by the time we get to
tuesday i'll show you that number just a
bit so if you plan to do some walking or
recreating tomorrow here's how it looks
all right so in the morning hours not
too much of an improvement we're going
to say fair rather than good because
we're still talking at this time
still around the mid 80s at this hour by
the time you get to 10 a.m like i
pinpointed out to you yeah poor
conditions this is brian right here
golfing noontime all right excessive
heat warnings still remain in effect
until eight o'clock tomorrow for the las
vegas valley 85 overnight very warm
south breezes will keep around some
breezes at least for the early evening
hours 109 tomorrow like we talked about
breezy and very hot so we're going to
keep around breezy winds tomorrow with
the stronger winds coming on sunday
saturday temperatures here you go
hottest spots are going to be death
valley 120.
laughlin 117 las vegas 109 mount
charleston look at that that's the place
to go mount charleston tomorrow lee
canyon kyle canyon 80 degrees mid 70's
for kyle canyon eight day forecast
temperatures show a cooling trend by the
time we get to sunday look at that drop
into 93 degrees on tuesday i'll take it
but it won't last long because we're
gonna heat up again later in the week
i've got more in your forecast coming up
here on eight news now